Veronica vanderhall is a 14 year old
high school student who has a rebellious
nature and an I don't give a Frick
attitude she never listens to her
teachers or her parents often gets into
arguments with her friends and gets the
lowest grades in class however Veronica
was not always like this until one year
ago she was a fun-loving caring and
intelligent girl who is one of the class
Toppers but during summer holidays she
met some new friends and learned about
the ecological problems like global
warming deforestation and so on now
Veronica has become an aggressive vegan
oh dear she also incites regular
protests in her school against the usage
of animal products plastic and other
stuff which she is totally against all
the teachers students and even her
parents are fed up with her Antics
however Veronica could care less she is
adamant on forcing her ideologies onto
other students whether they want them or
not she should just throw some tomato
sauce on a painting that'll do the trick
unfortunately for her one day she is
summoned to the principal's office and
give even a lecture about her degrading
grades and bad attitude Veronica still
doesn't pay attention and continues
acting smart so the principal suspends
her for an indefinite period finally the
spoiled teenager realizes the gravity of
the situation and tries to apologize but
it's too late the principle has already
made up her mind and she won't change it
for anything later at home Veronica has
to hear another lecture session This
Time by her parents they explain how she
is completely changed in the last year
and that sometimes it feels as if
someone is kidnapped their daughter and
replaced her with an imposter the
parents also mention how Veronica used
to play with them go places with them
and even snuggle at night with them I
mean she probably shouldn't do that
anymore but now she is a shadow of the
person she used to be then Veronica's
dad brings out a pamphlet of a certain
institution named Miss Genevieve's
school for difficult girls which
apparently specializes in disciplining
girls with differences in social
behaviors if you're a vegan we're gonna
Force food to meet in other words this
school is an expert in straightening out
spoiled girls Veronica takes a good look
at the pamphlet and says that she
doesn't want to go however the parents
make her understand that she doesn't
have much of a choice the following day
they drive their daughter to miss
Genevieve school for difficult girls the
main building looks like a Gothic castle
and the principle of the school is none
other than Miss Genevieve moreover all
the students have the same Eerie haircut
and it appears as if they are not normal
after a while miss Genevieve meets
Veronica's parents and assures them that
she will discipline their girl and send
her back home in a few months she also
reveals that she has straightened out
more than a thousand girls during her
tenure here no matter how rebellious or
arrogant they are Miss Genevieve always
finds a way to help them meanwhile
Veronica's Mom finally brings up the
question why all the girls in the school
have the same haircut with a menacing
stare Miss Genevieve replies that the
haircut is simply an extension of their
uniform which signifies Simplicity
obedience and honesty as well as bad
taste according to her the young mind is
a sponge and the girls come here soaked
in bad habits all she has to do is give
them a little squeeze just then a girl
named Heather Corbett arrives and Miss
Genevieve introduces her as Veronica's
roommate Heather quickly charms Mr and
Mrs vanderhall by greeting them politely
but soon she Whispers something into
Miss Genevieve's ear it turns out that
she is ratted on Veronica for chewing
gum something which is strictly
prohibited inside the school premises
Miss Genevieve points the rule out and
tells Veronica to take the gum out
however the latter shows her rebellious
Nature by sticking it to a nearby pole
badass after a while Veronica's parents
depart and Heather escorts her to their
room it is a dark and gloomy looking
room which consists of only two beds a
table and an alarm clock as Veronica is
unpacking Heather politely offers to
help but gets declined Veronica then
chastises her for ratting her out
earlier she also asks Heather to cut the
act as their creepy principle is not
here anymore however to her surprise
Heather mentions that she is just
following the rules and that she will
continue doing so until they are inside
the school premises weirded out by her
behavior Veronica aims to relax by
listening to some music on her MP3
speaker but even this time Heather
intervenes she quickly turns off the
speaker and warns Veronica that music is
not allowed here before leaving she also
says that Mr Welch will be giving her a
new haircut soon something about that
sounds so gross the next morning
Veronica is woken up sharp at 5am by a
combination of the alarm clock and
Heather still sleepy she gets dressed in
her school uniform and heads to the
canteen where all the girls are enjoying
their breakfast and chattering the
strange thing is that none of them are
shouting and laughing like normal girls
their age would normally do they also
appear to be dull and lethargic almost
as if they are robots meanwhile Veronica
goes to the counter for some food but
learns that they only serve sausage and
bacon oh no this means that she will
have to change her vegan lifestyle from
now on the scene then cuts to the class
where a male history teacher David is
explaining different events from the
past where children disobeyed their
parents and got punished it turns out
that in this school even all the classes
are designed to brainwash the students
to be obedient and polite Veronica finds
the information very false and
interrupts David saying children have
every right to be impolite because their
age makes them immature and carefree
hearing this the entire class becomes
shocked as this is the first time
someone has contradicted their teacher
however David calms them down mentioning
that Veronica will soon become polite
before the class ends he also asks her
why she hasn't gotten her hair cut yet
shortly after Veronica is wandering
around the playground When Miss
Genevieve summons her to her office on
reaching there she notices the barber Mr
Welch waiting for her surprisingly he
starts taking measurements of her head
and even asks her age something which is
definitely not required for a haircut
after noting down all the details Mr
Welch mentions that he won't be able to
book a haircut appointment until at
least the next week as he is totally
busy for the next few days however when
Miss Genevieve insists he cancels one
appointment and Promises to give
Veronica a haircut the following day at
this point Veronica has started to
realize that something is really wrong
with this school they don't even have
iPads so that the teachers don't have to
do their jobs hence at midnight while
her roommate is asleep she packs her
belongings and prepares to escape the
school but as soon as she gets out of
the main door a fellow student named
Claire stops her revealing that it's not
easy to escape the place there are
electric fences surrounding the school
and on the road several guards are
always patrolling following this the two
introduce themselves and Claire takes
Veronica to her room there she shows her
the sketches of two former students who
apparently tried to escape but were
caught they had calculated all the
movements of the guards but despite this
they were still caught they were
probably turned into Piggies too and
made into bacon after the Revelation
Claire tells Veronica that she doesn't
have much time left as her haircut is
scheduled for the next day she claims
that the haircut is what changes the
students into dull robots Veronica is
obviously confused by all this so Claire
decides to show her something she leads
her through a secret tunnel and soon
they reach a room where Miss Genevieve
Mr Welch and another student are present
the student is tied to a chair and she
keeps asking to be released but miss
Genevieve is unfazed all she says is
don't worry my child you will be polite
in no time saying this she orders the
barber Dr Welch to initiate the process
as the tied up student screams in fear
he puts a strange helmet on her head and
starts giving her a haircut after a
while her hairstyle has changed and so
is her behavior the girl who was
rebellious arrogant and rude just a few
minutes ago has now become calm and
polite Veronica who is watching from a
distance with Claire finally understands
how the students are straightened out
here she does that Tech makes no sense
meanwhile Claire reveals that she
fractured her head when she was a child
and the metal plate had to be put inside
her head as a precaution this plate
apparently saved her from turning into
one of those doll students when she got
a haircut last year later as the two
continue talking Claire mentions the
reason why she doesn't want to escape
she and her sister both arrived at the
school on the same day but only she
retained her sanity now if she leaves
alone she fears that Genevieve will harm
her sister hearing all this Veronica
promises to come up with a plan to
release all the students from the spell
that is constricting them the following
morning at the canteen she tries to
encourage the students to be rebellious
by whistling but ends up getting
reprimanded by Miss Genevieve during
their conversation Veronica accidentally
reveals that she and Claire witnessed
the haircut session of a fellow student
this angers Miss Genevieve and she
promises to change Veronica for good in
the evening a few hours later a scared
Veronica rushes to her only friend
Claire's room only to find out that
she's gotten a brand new haircut it
turns out that after Veronica
inadvertently revealed that they were
spying on Mr Welch the other night Miss
Genevieve approached Claire removed the
metal plate from the head and gave her
another haircut now she is emotionless
and dull like all the other students
with this Veronica's Only Hope of
Escaping The Wretched school is gone
feeling sorry for herself instead of
feeling guilty for getting her only
friend lobotomized classic Veronica
later she lies in her bed waiting for
Miss Genevieve to take her away and
change her forever meanwhile her
roommate Heather arrives and mentions
that it's supper time so they should go
however Veronica is in no mood instead
she starts talking about her childhood
days where she used to be happy and
didn't care a bit about what was
happening in the world she then asks
Heather about what it's like to live a
boring and controlled life but as
expected the latter doesn't understand a
word she is saying despite this Veronica
decides to give her roommate a parting
gift she brings out her MP3 speaker and
hands it to Heather who is speechless
throughout the encounter in the
background some static noises can be
heard implying that Heather is trying to
recall her past memories suddenly she
presses a button on the speaker and a
pop song starts playing Heather feels
excruciating pain in her ears but after
a while she calms down surprisingly she
has regained her sanity and all the
memories that she had before the haircut
in fact she doesn't even remember how
she ended up in this school this makes
Veronica very happy as she has finally
found an antidote to cure the six
students holy crap Nicki Minaj is good
for something hence without wasting any
time she starts plotting something with
Heather after a while she goes to miss
Genevieve's office and mentions that she
is ready for the haircut the two then
head towards Mr Welch's barber shop but
along the way Veronica changes her
attitude and starts insulting Miss
Genevieve at the same time she signals
her roommate to initiate their plan
Heather who is actually in Miss
Genevieve's office brings out the MP3
speaker and puts it right next to a
microphone then she turns on the speaker
and the same pop song from earlier
starts blasting from all the
announcement devices in the school at
first all the students are deeply
affected by the music but soon they turn
into their real selves Claire who is in
the canteen finally reconvenes with her
sister after a year in the final scene
all the girls come out on the playground
screaming and having fun like normal
teenagers do miss Genevieve tries to
order them back inside their rooms but
to no avail with the spell now broken
the girls are wild and carefree as they
should be the movie ends as all the
students including Veronica Heather and
Claire run towards the exit gate of the
school probably about to get mowed down
by the guards subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching